digamos que tenemos un poco de amoniaco
gaseoso nh3 gaseoso por eso la g entre
paréntesis y esto lo combinamos con
oxígeno molecular que también es un gas
y esa reacción produce algo de monóxido
de nitrógeno n o monóxido sólo hay un
oxígeno y también es un gas a veces le
llaman óxido nítrico que no se debe
confundir con el óxido nitroso que es n
2 o el gas de la risa pero no nos
desviamos del problema entonces esto es
óxido nítrico o monóxido de nitrógeno un
contaminante que proviene del humo de
los cigarros y creo que también se usa
en el cuerpo humano pueden buscarlo en
internet el amoniaco es un fertilizante
muy importante y bueno ya saben sobre el
oxígeno y también se produce algo de
agua más h2o
y nos dicen que tenemos 34 gramos de
amoniaco
este es el amoniaco 34 gramos de
y nos dan 32 gramos de oxígeno molecular
32 gramos de otros la pregunta es
cuántos gramos de monóxido de nitrógeno
o también llamado óxido nítrico se
producen cuánto en él se va a producir
en eeuu
este es un problema de este kilómetro y
es importante asegurarse de que tengamos
una ecuación balanceada antes de hacer
cualquier otra cosa en este caso no creo
que esté balanceada vamos a confirmar
veamos tenemos nitrógeno aquí y
nitrógeno acá está balanceado tenemos 3
hidrógenos aquí recuerden es mejor
empezar con lo más difícil y dejar la
molécula en un solo átomo al final
hidrógeno tenemos 3 hidrógenos del lado
izquierdo y del lado derecho
tenemos dos hidrógenos dos hidrógenos
pensemos cómo podemos tener tres
hidrógenos del lado derecho si
multiplicamos esto por uno y medio es
decir 1.5 ahora tenemos tres hidrógenos
del lado izquierdo y de este lado 1.5
por 2 tenemos tres hidrógenos del lado
derecho las cosas se ven bien
ok y ahora del lado derecho cuantos
tenemos 2 oxígenos del lado izquierdo 2
aquí cuantos oxígenos hay del lado
derecho
aquí hay oxígeno y un oxígeno en esta
molécula pero tenemos 1.5 de toda la
molécula así que tenemos uno y medio
oxígenos aquí y por acá uno tenemos dos
y medio oxígenos del lado derecho y sólo
tenemos dos en esta molécula que tenemos
que hacer como podemos tener dos y medio
oxígenos aquí bueno si multiplicamos si
multiplicamos por cinco cuartos es decir
1.25 cinco cuartos por dos es igual a
cinco medios que es 2.5 entonces tenemos
dos y medio oxígenos cinco cuartos por
dos
2.5 y uno más 1.5 también es 2.5 así que
ya hemos balanceado pero no hemos
terminado pues no podemos dejar la
ecuación con estos números decimales
vamos a multiplicar toda la ecuación por
si queremos deshacernos de todo esto
podemos multiplicar todo por 2 no mejor
por 4 para cancelar este 4 en el
denominador entonces si multiplicamos
toda la ecuación por 4 nos queda lo voy
a escribir aquí abajo
nos quedan cuatro moléculas de amoniaco
o si lo quieren ver en términos de mol
tenemos cuatro moles de amoniaco cuatro
veces 6.0 2 por 10 a la 23 moléculas de
amoniaco de cualquier forma está bien
5 moléculas voy a dejarlo como moléculas
más 5 moléculas de oxígeno molecular y
recuerde estamos viendo esto en términos
de en términos ya se me olvidó que iba a
decir bueno estamos multiplicando todo
por 4 y se producen 4 moles de óxido de
nitrógeno 4 n o más multiplicamos ambos
lados por 4 entonces más 6 aguas 6 h2o
ahí lo tienen practicamos un poco con el
balanceo de ecuaciones químicas pero
volvamos al problema original nos dan 34
gramos de amoniaco 34 gramos de esto hay
que calcular a cuántos gramos de
amoniaco equivale esto entonces cuál es
la masa atómica del amoniaco bueno más
bien cuál es la masa molecular del
amoniaco
el nitrógeno digamos que estamos
trabajando con el nitrógeno 14 entonces
tiene una masa de 14 y el hidrógeno
tiene una masa de 1
entonces cuál es la masa molecular del
amoniaco cada nitrógeno tiene una masa
de 14 y cada hidrógeno tiene una masa de
1 recuerden los hidrógenos son raros
porque no tienen neutrones sólo tienen
un protón y un electrón son neutros esto
es 3 por 1 porque tenemos tres átomos de
hidrógeno
entonces la masa de una molécula de
amoniaco es 14 + 3 es igual a 17
unidades de masa atómica
otra forma de escribirlo es que si una
molécula de amoniaco es igual a 17
unidades de masa atómica entonces un mol
un molde amoniaco es igual a 17 gramos
17 gramos entonces cuántos moles de
amoniaco tenemos si nos dan 34 gramos de
amoniaco y un mol
es igual a 17 gramos entonces tenemos
dos moles 34 es dos veces 17 así que
estos son dos moles tenemos dos moles de
amoniaco ahora veamos cuánto oxígeno
molecular tenemos oxígeno molecular la
masa atómica del oxígeno es 16 aquí hay
que tener cuidado porque tenemos 32
gramos pero estamos hablando de masa
molecular aunque bueno será lo mismo
pero siempre hay que asegurarse de que
tenemos si es sólo un átomo de oxígeno o
si es óxido
no molecular
entonces la masa atómica del oxígeno es
16 vamos a confirmarlo en la tabla
periódica que la tenemos aquí abajo
aquí tenemos 16
cuál es la masa de la molécula de
atómica o dos si son dos oxígenos
entonces esto será dos veces 16 que es
igual a 32 unidades de masa atómica
entonces si una molécula es igual a 32
unidades de masa atómica cuantos moles
de oxígeno tenemos nos dieron
exactamente 32 gramos de oxígeno que
equivale exactamente a un mal entonces
tenemos 34 gramos de amoniaco que
equivalen a 2 moles voy a escribirlo de
otro color
dos moles de amoniaco
y uno
un amor de la molécula de oxígeno cuando
observamos la reacción podemos ver que
por cada cuatro moles de amoniaco
necesitamos cinco moles de oxígeno o que
por cada cinco moles de oxígeno
necesitamos cuatro moles de amoniaco
pero algo no cuadra aquí porque hay más
moles de oxígeno que de amoniaco y en lo
que nosotros estamos trabajando hay
menos moles de oxígeno que de los que
necesitamos para el amoniaco verdad en
un mundo ideal si tenemos dos moles de
amoniaco necesitaríamos 2.5 moles de
oxígeno la relación amoniaco oxígeno
voy a escribirlo por acá
la relación lo pondré en otro color la
relación del amoniaco nh3 oxígeno
en nuestra ecuación balanceada voy a
enmarcar la porque es muy importante la
relación de esta reacción es 4 a 5
entonces si tengo dos moles de amoniaco
cuántos moles de oxígeno necesito bueno
necesito 2.5 moles de oxígeno aquí son
cuatro quintos y si duplicamos estos
números obtenemos 4 entre 5 entonces
necesito 2.5 moles de oxígeno pero yo
sólo tengo un molde oxígeno
entonces el oxígeno es el reactivo
limitante en esta reacción es el
reactivo
limitante reactivo limitante
y como les dije en otro vídeo se puede
usar la palabra reactivo o restante
aunque en español es más común decir
reactivo entonces el oxígeno es el
reactivo limitante y tenemos amoniaco de
sobra si tenemos un molde oxígeno
cuántos moles de amoniaco reaccionarán
con esto para esta reacción en lugar de
tener 5 moles de oxígeno tengo un mal 12
en lugar de 5 cuanto amoniaco
reaccionará con eso bueno la relación
era 4 a 5 entonces son punto 8 amoniacos
4 es el 51.8 es a 1 así que
esencialmente si tomo toda esta ecuación
y la divido entre 5 lo que tendré será
esto entre 5.8 de óxido nítrico
6 entre 5 moles de h2o y la pregunta
inicial era cuántos gramos de monóxido
de nitrógeno se producirán bueno si
tenemos un molde oxígeno se producirán
punto 8 moles de óxido nítrico cuál es
la masa molecular del monóxido de
nitrógeno el nitrógeno tiene 14 unidades
de masa atómica y el oxígeno 16 así que
una molécula de monóxido de nitrógeno
una molécula de monóxido de nitrógeno n
o es igual a 30 unidades de masa atómica
16.02 por 10 a la 23 moléculas de n
son igual a 30 gramos cuantos moles se
producen en esta reacción
cuando el oxígeno es el reactivo
limitante y tengo un molde oxígeno aquí
sólo se producen 18 moles de monóxido de
nitrógeno entonces si un mal es igual a
30 gramos punto 8 moles de n o son punto
8 por 30
esto es igual a 24 gramos se podrán
producir hasta 24 gramos de monóxido de
nitrógeno y tal vez se estén preguntando
si solo estamos usando punto 8 moles de
amoniaco y originalmente teníamos dos
moles de amoniaco que pasó con todo lo
que había de amoniaco suponiendo que lo
hicimos bien terminamos con 24 gramos de
monóxido de nitrógeno porque usamos
usamos
punto 8 moles de amoniaco punto 8 moles
de amoniaco y sobraron
sobraron
1.2 moles de amoniaco si quieren pueden
calcular a cuántos gramos del amoniaco
que teníamos originalmente equivale esto
solo hay que retomar a cuántos gramos
equivale un molde de amoniaco que son 17
y multiplicar eso por 1.2 bueno espero
que les haya parecido interesante si aún
se les hace confuso pueden volver a ver
este vídeo pongan pausa y traten de ir
resolviendo el problema por su cuenta
pero sobre todo traten de encontrarle
sentido la parte más difícil son las
conversiones de moles a gramos si logran
hacer eso bien traten de entender las
relaciones molares si esto es una
relación 4 a 5 entonces habrá menos
amoniaco que oxígeno pero si solo tengo
un molde oxígeno necesitaría tener menos
de un molde amoniaco aún cuando me
dieran 2 o más pero en este ejemplo el
oxígeno ha sido el reactivo limitante
si tuviéramos no sé 10 moles de oxígeno
y 2 moles de amoniaco en ese caso el
amoniaco sería el reactivo limitante
porque tendría más de lo necesario de
oxígeno por cada 2 moles de amoniaco
tendría 2.5 moles de oxígeno 10 moles de
oxigeno serían demasiado hasta el
próximo vídeo